[Música]
bom dia meu nome é paulo natan e eu sou
aluna do 1º ano do ensino médio e bom
hoje eu vou falar sobre os jogos como
meio de combate ao acúmulo de lixo
eletrônico ea vulnerabilidade social
bom primeiro um pouco sobre mim
bom eu gosto muito de engenharia gosto
de competir em várias olimpíadas mas
vamos ao tema bom ano passado alguns
colegas e eu fazemos o curso de
empreendedorismo aplicada ao
desenvolvimento de jogos eo nosso
professor francisco tupi nos propôs um
desafio desenvolver uma pesquisa
científica relacionada aos jogos que
contribuísse no combate a uma emergência
social e ao mesmo tempo fosse de custo
zero
então nós fizemos um brainstorm e uma
lista das emergências sociais que nós
conseguimos identificar as duas que se
destacaram foram a questão do lixo
eletrônico um dos resíduos cuja produção
mais aumenta a cada ano ea outra questão
foi a dos jovens em situação de
vulnerabilidade social
então nós pensamos em uma maneira de
introduzir os jogos nessa temática e foi
aí que nós decidimos fazer um manual que
ensinar seus jovens socialmente
vulneráveis como fazer os seus próprios
jogos utilizando o lixo eletrônico como
material dessa forma
promoveremos a reciclagem do lixo
eletrônico e ao mesmo tempo a inclusão
desses jovens no contexto da cultura
maker mas sem depender de equipamentos
de ponta como impressoras 3d
simplesmente com a sua criatividade e ao
mesmo tempo haver uma inovação escolar
no que diz respeito ao desenvolvimento
de jogos já que esse tipo de atividade
permite com que os jovens desenvolvam
uma série de inteligências bom
a partir disso nós adotamos uma
abordagem indutiva para a pesquisa já
que partimos sempre da nossa própria
visão mais particular e fomos de
encontrar padrões mais gerais em todo o
procedimento da pesquisa
nós adotamos um
método qualitativo já que não nos
baseamos em estatísticas matemáticas mas
simplesmente no que nós poderíamos
identificar empiricamente quanto aos
jogos quanto aos materiais ea escrita do
manual e foi aí que a nossa pesquisa se
dividiu em duas vertentes uma de criação
do manual para a qual nós utilizamos a
escala likert uma escala de 1 a 5 em que
um é o pior de 5 melhor pra comparar uma
série de jogos e de materiais para
escrever o nosso manual ea outra parte
da pesquisa foi a fase de aplicação na
qual desenvolvemos um questionário
qualitativo para avaliar a experiência
dos usuários com o nosso manual bom aqui
tem um esquema de como foi todo o
processo da pesquisa
no começo nós colhemos algumas
referências bibliográficas pra nos
situarmos melhor em relação ao tema e em
seguida fomos para uma etapa em que
fizemos engenharia reversa não só de
diversos materiais mais dois jogos em si
mediante os princípios da ética hacker
dessa forma nós poderemos compreender
como cada jogo funciona em sua essência
e por exemplo que faz o jogo da velha
ser o jogo da velha
de modo que pudéssemos ensinar outras
pessoas através do manual como construir
esse jogo e se esse jogo bom e com a
desmontagem dos materiais nós poderíamos
identificar quais eram mais facilmente é
desmontados e em seguida nós também
confeccionamos alguns dos jogos que nós
fizemos engenharia reversa
dessa forma identificamos os melhores
jogos segundo uma série de critérios
estabelecidos os melhores materiais
também como vocês podem ver nessa tabela
na no slide bom é foi com essa tabela
que nós fizemos a avaliação desses jogos
com a escala likert e foi aí que nós
podemos finalmente escrever o nosso
manual e aplicá lo
essa aplicação ocorreu junto à escola da
comunidade que é um projeto social do
meu colégio que esse projeto atende a
mais de 1.200 jovens da comunidade de
paraisópolis
dessa forma seriam jovens que
representarão o nosso público-alvo isto
é os jovens em situação de
vulnerabilidade social
bom então
fizemos essa essa fase de aplicação do
nosso manual que consistiu de chamar
alguns desses jovens para uma oficina
com o manual
em um primeiro momento nós apenas
observamos os jovens trabalhando com o
manual e fazendo seus próprios jogos em
nosso auxílio já que um dos critérios
que o nosso manual deveria cumprir era o
fato de ele poder ser compreendido sem
ajuda de outras pessoas e dessa forma
ele seria mais replicável então no final
dessa etapa nós aplicamos o questionário
qualitativo para identificar melhor qual
foi a experiência desses usuários com o
nosso manual
analisamos os resultados tomamos algumas
conclusões e fizemos melhorias no manual
aqui temos algumas fotos dos jovens
trabalhando e fazendo seus próprios
jogos a partir do dos teclados de
computador que foram o material
selecionado para a atividade uma vez que
era o material mais facilmente
desmontado e que apresentava mais
possibilidades de adaptação para criar
jogos e aqui temos também algumas fotos
dos jovens lendo manual é muito
interessante destacar que os jogos
desenvolvidos pelos jovens foram muito
mais elaborados que os jogos que nós
mesmos havíamos produzido em uma etapa
anterior da pesquisa o provando a
eficiência do nosso manual instruir os
jovens como fazer os seus próprios jogos
aqui temos alguns dos resultados da
pesquisa ou seja as tabelas comparativas
e os gráficos que nós elaboramos para
escolher quais jogos e materiais que
deveriam estar no nosso manual
então nesses gráficos nós podemos
observar que o teclado é o material que
melhor cumpre com os critérios
estabelecidos e os jogos que melhor
cumprem com esses critérios que incluem
jogabilidade facilidade de construir e
entre outros
os melhores jogos nesses critérios
seriam jogo mancala resta um e também o
jogo da velha que foram os jogos que nós
incluímos no nosso manual bom e abaixo
temos alguns gráficos que nós
desenvolvemos a partir dos resultados do
nosso questionário que tinha tanto
perguntas objetivas
sim ou não por exemplo se eles gostaram
da experiência quando perguntas abertas
como porque eles gostaram e é
interessante ressaltar que todos os
jovens disseram ter gostado da
experiência e nas suas justificativas
nós organizamos aqui os principais
termos utilizados por eles e um termo
que se destaca é o termo da de trabalhar
e se divertir mostrando que é uma
atividade que que promove engajamento e
também eles falaram de reciclagem
destacando o caráter sustentável da
nossa pesquisa
bom como conclusões do nosso projeto
tivemos que o manual de fato promove uma
atividade que que incentivar o
engajamento já que como nós podemos
observar na fase de aplicação os jovens
em nenhum momento se distanciavam da
tarefa de fazer os jogos e sempre
estavam sorrindo mostrando que gostavam
da atividade que estavam envolvidos e
não nós não precisamos ficar falando
para eles voltarem a fazer os jogos eles
não se distrair
o manual de fato pode ser compreendido
sem a ajuda de outras pessoas já que os
jovens desenvolveram os seus próprios
jogos sem o nosso auxílio nem mesmo
quanto a algumas informações do manual
eles fizeram totalmente sozinhos e por
isso o manual pode ser facilmente
reproduzido e passado outras pessoas
bom o manual permite que usuários têm os
seus processos criativos respeitados e
valorizados já que uma das coisas que
nós fizemos questão de destacar no
início do manual foi o fato de ele ser
apenas um exemplo de algumas formas de
se confeccionar alguns jogos mas
destacamos que o usuário é livre para
que a luz da maneira como desejar
inclusive outros jogos que não estejam
no manual e importante ressaltar que um
dos jogos que os jovens fizeram foi o
batalha naval e um campo minado que era
um dos jogos que nós nem mesmo havíamos
colocado no manual mostrando que eles de
fato conseguiram estrapolar dos limites
do manual que é positivo
bom o manual promove a reciclagem do
lixo eletrônico já que como vocês
puderam ver esses jogos foram feitos
totalmente com material reciclado ou
seja os teclados de computador
e também combate à vulnerabilidade
social permitir que esses anjo esses
jovens que são socialmente vulneráveis
possam desenvolver uma série de
habilidades como trabalho em equipe
criatividade e sejam incluídos no
contexto da cultura maker sem depender
de um de um alto custo e acima de tudo
manual pode ser utilizado por escolas e
outros tipos de instituições como
bibliotecas ou museus para que essas
instituições possam se equipar a custo
zero com jogos feitos pelas próprias
crianças que ao mesmo tempo que
contribuem para o meio ambiente ao
reutilizar esse tipo de resíduo lixo
eletrônico elas desenvolvem uma série de
inteligências e habilidades bom muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]